thank you very much manish for for the
introduction thank you very much
everybody it's not to be uh here uh
albeit virtually so thank you for having
me thank you for attending this talk
uh so yes uh i will talk about visual
representations broadly controlled
and
that refers to what manish was saying
like visualization we have visual
representation creative uh authoring we
have visual representations as well and
so i will talk about this these concepts
uh involved so
by visual representations what i mean is
any depiction of information that is
based on visuals
rather than linear and sequence or and
sequential verbalization or text and
this includes uh graphical elements
actually in user interface such as
buttons and icons
which if you think about it are visual
representations of comments or
you can think of scrolling bars as well
which would be a visual representation
of the notion of viewport within a
document
or a progress bar also which would be a
verification of system progress doing a
task so these are visual representations
as per our definition drawings sketches
are also visual representations of
information when they capture concepts
and ideas
photorealistic
or even real-life visual representations
of her formation exists too such as a
model of
the half alex that we see here in the
photograph from linux towling these are
also visual representations and of
course which might have been the one
that
came
into our mind immediately visual
representation
of actual data
such as this equals charts
or data views that we can generate in
visual analytics systems
so for this talk today uh i thought i
would go over why choosing appropriate
visual representations in user
interfaces
is such an important design decision to
guide and empower people and also i want
to show that it is far from being a
trivial task
uh so often times as well uh visual
representations we think of them as an
output modality and i will try to
convince you and show you also that it's
very important to consider them also and
their quality as an input modality
so let's get started what are
visualization visual representations
great for so
the first argument that you will often
hear is visual representations of
information so powerful because they
allow externalize uh to externalize
cognition
basically because you pull information
from your head and put it in the world
in a visual in a visual form you
basically free up cognitive resources
and instead of working with the
information that is stored in your head
you can use up your um very powerful
perceptual system to acquire the
necessary information
as you are at the task
so let's take this example that i'm sure
many of you are probably familiar with
already it's a node visualization
it's a simple visual representation that
shows the number of murders committed
using firearms in the state of florida
for the past 30 years
and so what happened is that in 2005
which we see on the chart uh the state
of florida enacted uh the stand your
ground law
that basically uh makes it legal to
shoot one's way out of any situation
that feels threatening
and so what happens
after uh the law was enacted
uh what is this chart uh really showing
us at the glance
we see a club drop right
it's great the state seems to be safer
um
after the the
the law was enacted which is good news
the very fact that it's legal to shoot
someone for self defense
seems to have successfully discouraged
criminal acts and resulted in less
deadly consequences
but wait a minute
is that really the story that distrust
[Music]
here
i i i don't have like the the raise of
hand because i don't see the gallery but
did you guys pay attention to the axis
in the chart if you take a second you
might find out that the axis the y-axis
actually goes downwards
and so basically if we turn it around
this chart and put it back in a
chronological order
which is a visualization that we would
be more used to this is uh this is what
we get the complete opposite story
and of course if you make it legal to
shoot people and you don't have any like
you know implications to that well
people more people get shot
so that's one of the aspects of what i
really mean when i talk about the power
of visual representations
so the chart that
we had before it doesn't technically lie
because you have a lot of the
information there but it is clearly a
malicious design aimed to mislead the
audience why because you're used to read
these type of charts with the y-axis
going upwards and it's well too easy not
to catch this this subtlety here and you
made a quick snap judgment by reading a
chart that you expect with respect to
conventions and standards and this
reliance on your previous experience
makes you less
acute at detecting subtleties in the
design
and i'm sure like of course many of you
would say i've never designed such a
chart it's a terrible idea well sure i
agree with that hopefully we don't
but
there might be some like you know uh
reasonable reasons why a truck might be
designed in an unconventional way
and also as a reader as a viewer do you
think that you know encountering such
shots you would never fall into such
trap ever so the answer is is no we
would we would get fooled and misled
uh because we we are too used we are so
used to to this type of visual
representation that it is very likely
that many of us would over confidently
rely
on the visual judgment and
interpretation here
so that brings me to the first lesson
and i will share some raw uh throughout
this talk so first lesson about visual
representation uh which is often like
you know uh
under under misunderstood or like you
know overlooked
decoding visual representation is
deceptively simple it's
uh here i showed an example that is
pretty obvious with a clear violation of
an established uh standard
but it's so big and obvious that it
actually isn't we got food or at least i
did like the first time i saw this trout
it took me a few you know somebody
actually telling me that the axis was
the wrong way
and there are plenty of other more
subtle cases that can be at play so um
there are many expectations an
assumption that you know one inherently
has when they approach visual
representations of information
and the context as well you may have
beliefs and be subject to confirmatory
bias or being a particular mindset or
situation that makes you more or less
secure to interpret a representation for
what it is it's easy to miss out on
something
so it's powerful
in this sense like you know in in not
always like the best way
here's another example so these uh
are two shots that show the same data
about access to safe
drinking water in two different
fictional cities
so uh can you guess what changed here i
believe like because now i have uh put
you in in the mindset of like paying
attention to the axis you might have
noticed that same data but axes have
changed on the left hand we have a
truncated axis where the values start at
81
and on the other axis we have like a an
axis y-axis that starts at zero and goes
all the way to 100 percent
so one question that we might have here
which one of those two representations
is better
form yourself
like you know an opinion here which one
do you believe we should go for
and as an answer i would say like well
actually none because it actually
depends
if you are trying to emphasize the
difference and allow an accurate reading
of this uh difference
and can compromise actually on that
create estimate of the magnitude of
those values then the left
representation is good
but it's often considered as being
deceptive
because uh it results in an exaggeration
of the difference
uh between two the two quantities
instead if you are trying to show the
magnitude then the right chart is better
but that makes perception of the
difference much more challenging
so by using one or the other you
understand that you will make one of
those tasks easier but also the other
tasks more difficult
and so that's
the second um
and that's the second lesson that i i
want to convey today like a design of
visual representations
involves making a trade-off decisions
almost always
each design will result in making it
better for some tasks and worse for
other tasks
is that uh inevitable well uh
sometimes
no if you consider that
only a single design choice is possible
but
here uh one question that we may wonder
why do we have to choose one or the
other why not presenting the viewer with
with both views right
uh if they are equally valuable in
different circumstances
and that's what uh jacob richie from uh
from stanford actually has studied
during his master was he uh as as at ufc
so this might ring a bell to some some
people in the audience but so basically
in this work what we thought is why not
adding simple interaction like a click
or hover over so that the viewer can
easily transition between the close-up
deceptive u
where the y-axis is truncated and the
full view that best represents the
magnitude on an absolute scale
and depending on the the task right the
the viewer can pose on the view that's
better to them at the time it is better
to them so we call this technique the
perceptual glimpses
and what's great if you think about my
my previous lesson is we didn't have to
choose you know which trade-off because
we present both views
but that's not all we didn't get away by
not having to choose between two
reasonable options we present them boss
but
there's still one decision to make as
designers of perceptual glimpses
we still have to decide which view
should we present first right
is it better to show the global reverse
to give a sense of magnitude and then
zoom into the details
or is it better to show the details
first and then contextualize this data
by transitioning to the non-truncated
views to appreciate the magnitude
so well open question but informed by
cognitive psychology science we thought
that showing the non-truncated view
first this one the overview first would
help
mitigate this exaggeration of the
difference that uh the tranquility view
that we see now uh tpd typically causing
viewers
and so one of the very interesting
findings uh that we we got from the
studies of these like which of you first
is that the overview first mantra
actually resulted in policy parents
finding themselves deceived
by the so-called non-deceptive yield the
non-truncated view
and they completely rethought the
validity of their initial assumption
after being presented you know the views
in this order rather than just adjusting
their initial estimate as as we were
expecting with the anchoring mechanism
here
so where i'm going here is that you
can't really avoid as a designer having
to make these decisions these design
decisions
uh thing is design of visual
representations involved to make all and
every decision about location and visual
aspect
because representing something visually
requires you to like you know create
this visual representation and put it
somewhere it
requires you to
find the location give it a shape and
the color and and oh and and so forth
and the very moment you make a decision
of laying things out in a particular
fashion
or shaping things up in a particular
fashion or use colors or texture in a
particular fashion for every such
decision be sure that you create
truly new opportunities of conveying uh
all information that you did not
intend to
because it's very likely that someone
may see a meaning where there is not
or that they would be influenced by one
of the perceptual or cognitive biases
that we mentioned a moment ago
but let me pause here i don't want you
to think that i'm telling you that uh no
matter what you do you never win this as
a designer it's not
uh
it's not the case that it's always like
you know going to be sub optimal or
worse uh wrong but
the the real truth is that it's not so
terrible visual representations really
do help uh truly in most cases
i'm just communicating here that uh how
easy it is to underuse their power or
even worse reverse their power against
your initial intent and that's
important to be well aware
of such caveats
so let me show some success stories
think about a physician who sees many
many patients within a day and of course
physicians don't try to remember all of
the facts about the patient out of
memory but instead they rely on patient
records
often in the form of textual notes
clinical notes and they use these
clinical notes to recollect what the
patient's clinical history is or to
assess what the patient's problems are
and patients record often quite
voluminous there is here like you know
only 15
of a single patient recalls with 300
notes a number which is not really
uncommon for patients with um chronic
illness
so
even though the information is out there
a text you know it's quite difficult to
go over it all and integrate out of the
information it contains
uh yet it is critical for the physician
to get as complete and as i create the
grasp
at the patient's clinical trajectory as
possible to provide appropriate care and
oftentimes within a very very
constrained you know time time period
and this is where like visual
representations uh more specifically
like you know visual analytics tool can
greatly help
so here we have data visualizations
powered by computational methods
such as natural language processing so
this tool particularly is called
doctorate it's a visual analytics tool
to support quick patient review through
interactive visual exploration of those
clinical notes that has been developed
by nicole sartonium from my group
the tool is interactive and is designed
such that on the left
you have a visual representation of the
frequency of symptoms or medications of
interest
within the patient's record that has
been automatically extracted from the
from the clinical notes
so we see here are cardiovascular
symptoms and medications in red
uh those relevant to
gastroenterology in purple uh
and so on and so forth
so these frequencies of mentions of
symptoms and medications
are shown over time
the oldest record at the top and the
most a recent one at the bottom
and we talk about visual representations
of information and you will find also in
this interface elements
that go beyond a data charts
in the middle here uh
that
of the interface we have that scroll bar
that is in fact a visual representation
of the collection of notes that is used
for specialization
uh we know like the viewport i was
telling earlier in the talk like this is
basically our scrolling bar with with
the cursor here
and uh so that that gives us an
indication of where we are in the
collection
and it also acts as you know a widget
with which we can interact uh to
navigate within the collection
and all of these together
make for a powerful interface for visual
exploration of data extracted from these
documents
and further featured enquired by the
physicians for interactions with various
widgets and data views themselves
so the visualizations uh the physician
sorry we evaluate this tool with uh all
form found more patient problems
more quickly and more accurately than
when using uh the textual notes on me so
this is showing the power of like you
know visual representations uh in action
together with with interaction as well
but
i brought up this project specifically
because related to our earlier
discussion perhaps some of you are
telling yourselves well
perhaps you know fanny we could improve
this visualization on the on the left
why might you think you the uh
that because
that's actually strange to represent
time from top to bottom we usually have
timelines going from left to right right
so
here our horizontal timeline will
perhaps be more natural for this
particular visualization because of
standards
and conventions and expectations as i
was referring to earlier
but there we are
this visualization rep this visual
representation is part of a larger
graphical ecosystem here we have the
notes on the right and because
we have them because it's important to
the physicians
to have access to this data and these
are presented in a traditional document
view for comfort of reading when needed
and we have this view on the right and
these view impose like linear textual
records that goes you know from from top
to bottom the chronological you know
order is as such right
and because of this
it is relevant to map out the
chronological dimension of our
visualization on the left to be
consistent with that of the document
view
and remember also the miniature scroll
bar that we have in the middle which is
also itself like a a verification and
material materialization of time as well
so yes the unconventional top to bottom
timeline
uh might not be
optimal in terms of like you know the
expectations and the standards but it
makes sense here to prevent the
cognitive load
associated with reconciling a spatial
mapping that is inconsistent between
different views otherwise
so that brings us to that uh you know uh
first lesson design of visual
representation should not happen in
isolation so it not only it is difficult
to design them on their own but
you know uh when designing visual
representations of information there are
contrast elements to taking into
consideration because of the of the
context it is embedded in so it's not
just taking each data view or widget and
apply visualization guidelines that
optimize perception and interpretation
within each view or best design
practices for that for that given widget
the interplay between the views and
other graphical elements in the
interface are to be factored in
and the interactions we want to support
as well so all of these impose
additional constraints or benefits that
make these design decisions less trivial
right
but which is okay there are traders we
we need to accept that by optimizing uh
something we may compromise on something
else
uh what's important to do and have in
mind is to uh make this choice you know
uh conscious and understand the
implications so we make trade-off we but
we understand what we compromise on and
we understand what what we optimize for
so speaking of interactive dashboards
here's another one that we recently
worked on in collaboration with
healthcare professionals at the hospital
for sick children in frontal
classical interactive dashboard with
several years like
uh stack charts and so on i'm not gonna
go uh in details about this interface in
particular but um
just to give the context
uh we are working here like in the
context of a pediatric intensive care
unit
where
clinicians have to do daily rounds
which involve monitoring the fluids in
every critically ill children and they
have to do that as a team every day
and so currently the way it works is
that we have an accredited clinician who
uh go over the data first of the
patients like in the in the world
and uh they take notes and then when it
comes like you know that the clinical
team meets together for the round they
provide a created summary of the
patient's status
orally
to a team of other experts from their
notes
and then the teams uh decides on whether
there are actions to take for the
patient
so no need to mention that of course the
speaking delivery of the information is
upon and importantly many errors in
these intensive care units
are preventable because there are common
errors which we aim to address with our
visualization dashboard
and it helps making all of the patients
information available to the clinicians
in a carefully designed you know user
center design an interactive dashboard
supports and can support specific
analytics analytical tasks
but the interesting thing here with this
project
is that we were actually taken aback by
the fact that this was not enough this
visual dashboard was not enough
why
because formulating patient problems
from interpreting a general
multi-purpose dashboard with all of this
data is cognitively demanding and
requires expertise
we use user-centered design with
clinicians you know involved all the way
through it's not like a lack of not
addressing their needs it's a lack of
you know having these multi-purpose
dashboards
still requires too much work
so yes interaction allows to generate
the relevant visual representations of
data
but our work suggests that technology
must go the extra mile in perfectly
aligning with the user's information
needs
by providing shortcuts to the created
data views
that present only the most important
information relevant to our clinical
context here
while also simultaneously pruning all of
the extraneous data anything that is not
relevant to that task
and basically this is what we did by
recentering our focus on the preeminent
goals of the clinicians which
boils down to a simple question what are
the patients problems that's the the
seed problem that they wanted to uh to
address and this visual dashboard don't
support that or need the extra work from
the clinician to do that themselves
and so what we propose is another
approach where the system actually
creates the data views relevant to the
clinician's context
by utilizing uh clinical problems as a
basis for data exploration so in a sense
the way it works our approach combines
the power of checklists
as a systematic and reliable way of
going over potential problems patients
and
the power of visual representations in
visualization dashboard to support
analysis of
rich multivitamin data
i'll take a minute to show very quickly
uh
interactive i'm not showing the entire
system here
but just very quickly
the way the system works
all right this is the screen that you
would have like you know as you enter
the world
on top of every bed you would see like
this you know patient problems uh you
know view of of every that you know of
the patients in in the world
and so this is what we call the like
overview like um um
a situation of awareness view where you
see like in a
at a glance from a distance you see the
list of potential problem and whether
the system has identified whether it is
a problem in red or whether it has not
been identified as a problem
and as you go and identify okay this
patient has four out of five problems
let's go and see them
uh the clinical team can start working
with uh like the more general you know
visualization dashboard here
and what i meant by uh you know having
those created views based on the patient
problem you see our checklist of problem
is still visible here on the left
and the way it works here
if the team say oh okay let's look at
you know the fluid creep problem that we
have first for this patient
as you go you can go and click
uh or just hover over this particular
problem and what the system does it it
creates the view of like the more
general dashboard for you to focus on
just the information that is relevant to
that particular problem
which you can always recontextualize uh
in the larger dashboard but we have
those shortcuts to like the relevant
views that we can consult with only the
information relevant to the problem
uh and everything else being you know
print out
we get back to the slides
up
so the fifth lesson i learned
the way working on this project and this
one in particular is
surely enough interaction is great to
support dynamic generation of the visual
representation that is most appropriate
to the task at hand and i'm a huge
proponent of that like don't show
everything at once give
the user you know the possibility of
interacting so that they can build the
the representation that is the most
relevant
uh you know to their task at the time
they they are working on the task
but the lesson learned here is like also
we should not
blindly rely on on that
interaction they are actually dangerous
to defer all of the work to the users uh
as well and it can because it can be
costly uh to them timely and cognitively
so um that's that's the lesson from this
particular work
interaction for sure have it but you
know uh it's important also to have
those shortcuts and think about the
preferred actions
to the users
speaking of interaction uh let me switch
gears here for a moment and talk about
one other very important aspect where a
design of visual representation is
critical which is their role as an input
you know
modality
so the visual aspects of things is
extremely important for us to make a
quick judgment about what the the object
affords that is what we can do with
different objects
we have two teapots here and what's
fascinating is that like immediately by
looking at them we know exactly from the
shape
that they can be grabbed by the handle
the top handle for for one and the side
handle for the other that this can
probably be uh you know tilty for
whatever is in them and that we can also
lift you know uh this lead that we have
on the top again grabbing this uh this
handle
this is well understood that the shape
conveys the the affordances of objects
and this notion has uh has been that you
know these visual cues have been
extensively studied and borrowed for the
design of graphical interfaces
notably the interactable widgets that
you find in interfaces here we know
that we have a button a written button
not because it's written button because
but because the visual representation of
these graphical elements before that
it's something that's that's popped and
that we can like push and click on right
but we can go much further than that
uh and that's why i get back to my
visual representation instead of having
buttons and menus on me with these
physical you know our properties
we can leverage the power of visual
representations
in their associated affordances by uh
doing what we call refining abstract
concepts that is make them visible to
enable and production let me explain
what i mean
here i have an example of an artist
drawing on the tablet and what's
interesting here is uh when the artist
figures out that the ear he drew doesn't
have the right shape he pulls up an
underlying mesh that you see here that
it can directly manipulate to distort
and adjust the strokes right
and this is uh what we call uh ref
refining the act of refining the concept
here of a stretchable canvas
that we see here as a visual
representation in the form of a mesh
that we can use for input
and that's the next lesson uh you know
these rubber presentations are actually
very powerful
when they act
uh as a manipulable rarification
of concepts that are the main objects of
interest that need to be interacted with
to complete a certain task
so in our example we have it was a shape
preserving distortion of the drawing
through a stretchable canvas
here's another example uh where we
implemented this idea of verification of
input going beyond a spatial canvas
here we have that crazy idea of
simultaneously painting in space and
time
powered by a motion flow that we have
like you know as input for the system
that we can for instance compute from a
video
and so that's what we propose with this
uh with technique that we called direct
paint
here you can draw in space in a typical
canvas and within the same interaction
you can invoke a sample path
that is a visual representation that
corresponds to the completed movement of
the pixel you painted on and drawing
along this path propagates the paints
through time
and so
that was the original video that you
might want to paint over
and through this interaction this
verification of space and time i you
have uh you can create something like
that in in less than five minutes uh
using this uh this approach this visual
representation for input
granted this is not very pretty i'm not
have not much of an artist but the point
really lies in the interaction
facilitated by that verification of the
space-time dimension to support our goal
of painting in space and through time
another example where we re-fi space and
time perhaps more traditionally this
time
uh that's the work from my former
master's students vicki bill billy uh
who worked on that project
the use case here is personal planning
so within the day there are many things
that we're doing that involve different
locations and different times
and recognizing that our lives are
planned in both space
and time
in this project we start to bridge the
gap between the traditional root mapping
and time scheduling tools
to support the general proposed spatial
temporal planning workflow
so we basically merge those two
traditional verification of space and
time
to work in sync so you have a map you
have a calendar and they are
synchronized but more interestingly uh
we augment this by also integrating the
notion of choice this is what you see
with this swipe motion
that vicky is performing on the demo
so this swipe motion that you saw here
is basically interacting with that
carousel of choices at this particular
time in the schedule to compare all of
my different options in context
and so we have actually a mechanism to
support the specification of the choices
so for example you can think of you know
i have a bunch of locations i need to go
to uh between you know 3 p.m and 5 p.m
and i'd like to fit as many as possible
and then the the system can compute you
know all of the different eating areas
that are possible by trying to fit as
many of those locations as possible
accounting for time uh you know
committing time a distance and so on and
so forth
all the types of choice would be like
you know you have a list of different uh
location but they all serve the same
purpose for example like restaurant for
lunch
and we have that other notion of you
know a choice uh which we call the
one-off the system knows that it should
pick one and only one of these options
optimizing the the choices based on the
rest of the
schedule
but the point is uh really back to our
visual representation is we have that
explicit you know visual representation
for space
time but also the actual choices in the
form of that scroll through carousel
in context
so remember these were examples of
representation as manipulable
verifications of concepts
to be interacted with
and what's interesting here is that
these reapplications are part of the
system that is they have been designed
by the system designer so they're part
of the design and we interact through
them
but they don't have to be always uh by
that i mean the user can actually also
draw these verifications themselves
for instance
say that you want to create an
animation
uh i bet rubaiyat will talk more in
depth about all of these dynamic
representations in a few weeks i saw it
was coming up in the schedule but yeah
this system that we actually
collaborated on together
which is called draco we can uh
draw the intended
spatial temporal behavior of the bubble
that we have here in this animation
that is we sketch the motion trajectory
and we can show also again uh by uh
example like the granular behavior of
all of those bubbles
and we can also sketch the dynamic
evolution of the bubbles uh about their
like you know uh speed and size
attribute as they go over time
so this is basically nothing like
new like this is a very concept of
sketch based interface but what i'm
trying to point out
here is
um these sketches are themselves visual
representations of concepts and ideas
that users can offer directly for input
so
visualization
visual representations are output and
they are input tool
and further bridging the tool we can use
uh these uh inputs to create a visual
vocabulary relevant to the domain
these verifications of concepts uh and
these can also be used as as output
so input output
all two purposes for visual
representations
so sketching our own vocabulary has
tremendous value because we can
appropriate the domain with our own
version
of what it is like that we think is an
appropriate visual representation
so looking back to visualization
visualizing data here say that i decided
to plot a day of activities relevant to
exposure of germs
and so i created that that particular
visual design for like you know my data
somebody cough is uh
in my vicinity i touch another breath i
cast myself i touched my face and washed
my hands so i drew those things and i
want them to be used as like graphical
vocabulary to create my visualization
and this is uh what like a resulting
visualization could look like i drew
this one manually oh it's the use of
copy paste but you know
point is like it was it was still costly
to to to design by hand
and so
what i'm going here is that you can use
these visual representation that you uh
you decide yourself
to actually serve as input and like as
vocabulary for your system uh to
actually create an output so that's
where we
bridge the gap like i use my drops in
this example as input that becomes my
you know different data element in this
tool
and these data elements are like you
know uh being um
change their their aspect their visual
aspect
based on the underlying data that i'm
trying to represent instead of having to
draw it myself
so this two data inc uh is is is
facilitating that
you sketch your input and then you have
like you know what we call a lazy data
binding which is changing the graphical
aspect of your different you know
graphical elements based on an
underlying you know data table that that
is there
so
this is important because uh we can use
visual representation as input and
output uh in in such a way that users
engage with information by uh really
letting them create the vocabulary of
the visual representation
i had to like a little bit of a chunk on
communication
i think i might go through it's just a
couple of uh slides so
yeah
it's important to like facilitate this
engagement with information like uh
having this authoring is is is helping
that and also thinking about visual
representation a little bit more broadly
like not only uh you know sketching and
drawing and like you know flat uh
representations so
here if we think about um one of the
problems we have sometimes with uh what
i call complex you know um mergers
uh we have for example the world that
four million and such four thousand
million hectares of forests uh in in
1990 and by 2015 this area had decreased
to uh three thousand nine uh
almost four million hectares of forest
and that lost of you know
129 million hectares over 25 years
period so you have all of the
information here
but really it's hard to imagine this to
really uh appreciate the magnitude of
this information how long is 25 years
really uh so
to help with this kind of latino complex
measure we can perhaps do something like
this this is equivalent to losing 20
soccer fields worth of forest
every minute for 25 years
we have something that we will
understand here a soccer field and a
minute
uh we all know what a minute
is like uh we could plot that using
charts and so but how much would that
help really does it really help
not much because uh my argument is we we
still don't have quite that visceral
reaction uh to to that information
and so we can do something like this
which is using a visual representation
but expanding it like so that we have
the dynamicity of it
so this uh task here is like to see how
fast you can color
20 soccer field within a span of a
minute and we saw the video uh
unfortunate here and we see that the
person even though they were trying to
be as fast as possible they failed
they didn't manage to color out of those
circle fields
but the point is palldozers they don't
fail
they get it every single minute they
take down the trees every single minutes
worth 20 soccer fields
and so now perhaps through this visual
representation that also it's temporal
you know kind of dimension to it you
appreciate the true meaning of a minute
in this context
and so this is an example of how you can
uh how i can make you experience the
data make it more relatable to you
rather than throwing numbers at you
using visual representation uh that rely
on on common you know um
uh
familiar objects and emotions
another example that i love to show is
like it's not because of the magnitude
always that complex measures are complex
it's also because the scale is complex
in the first place so i bet everybody in
the audience has drank a kind of pop at
least once in their life
and we might wonder you know uh
what are the nutritional facts about
about these particular drinks
there is actually a 39th gram of sugar
in a can should we be concerned is that
a lot i don't know this is a complex
scale
but if we use a different visual
representation that resonates
with us that is more familiar like sugar
cubes
that's where we would um start to be uh
seeing this data differently this is
worth ten trillion cubes
ten sugar cubes
do you see yourself putting ten sugar
cubes in your mug of coffee that's
that's pretty insane
so that's a notion that we explored you
know we call these visual representation
concrete scales where basically you know
use traditional familiar objects to
represent
or re-express you know
unity so that you you make them this you
know magnitudes or complex scales more
relatable to people
so that brings me to uh the ninth and
last lesson for this talk this is uh
uh a way to open your mind on how visual
representations can also be super
powerful if they are used
uh to facilitate a visceral experience
of information
so to conclude visual representations
yes they are very powerful they are very
difficult to design but when you have
identified the proper conceptual idea to
represent
then there are a ton of opportunities to
design an interesting meaningful
reification of these concepts and ideas
be it for
input output but more interestingly
input and output
and so people like to use a metaphor of
you know the hammer to qualify visual
representation or visualization like
they are a powerful tool by that they
can let us achieve you know great things
but they are also powerful
as in a destructive way as we saw we can
reduce or under use you know the power
and uh i guess i think this hammer is is
a little too weak of a metaphor for the
visual representation i think visual
representations are one of our most
powerful tool actually in in graphical
user interfaces
and uh it would be more like the god of
all of the armors with great powers and
that also requires you know like great
responsibility and want to use widely
so i'm closing here and distribute my
former in riyadh team and and uh former
uh head team's head nicola rousseau who
loved to use the tall's hammer as
to describe user interfaces the power uh
the power of them and visual
representation as well
so with that thank you very much for
your attention i'm i'm very happy to
take questions if any
i'll share my screen so i can see great
thank you fanny
um
we have time for questions uh some of
them may come in over uh
zoom and we'll we'll read those out to
you uh penny
so while we're waiting on questions
maybe i'll start with one which is
um
you know uh you the talk really uh
mentioned lots of great visual
representations and
and the power of those things and one
thing that i've uh
wondered a lot about is
you know really good visual
representations are often domain
specific and
uh
you know i wonder how you think about uh
how the domain interacts with the
representation
yeah that's that's a very good question
and one that i uh think
more and more about especially when we
think about the underlying data
structure
so um
[Music]
we have to think about you know
first and that's what we do as hci
researchers trying to
to understand the goals
analytical goals creative goals whatever
like you know tasks and goals that the
users have
and these goals and that's what where
i'm trying to like push for that you
know understanding of the concepts and
ideas
that are
at the core of those goals
uh you know if we were to talk no
computer computing solution we would use
different language we would use specific
language about you know really what are
the goals and and and how to achieve
those goals without the constraints of
like you know how do we show things and
and so on
and so by that i mean like you know if
we if we are to think about you know the
domain what are the goals and and really
try to like
understand these objects and concepts
and from there we start to think about
what would be a good representation what
would be the good you know
um
way of representing this concept both
for input and output uh that's where we
will get to to create those novel uh
those novel um or leverage the power of
visual visual representation much better
this is what i'm trying to hint at with
this like space-time kind of thing why
not using like another traditional
static uh like a horizontal you know um
timeline because it's it's not the the
mess the closest you know visual
representation to the concept i'm really
touching that and that's that's very
true it's it's domain specific we can
have like more general you know purpose
tools but they will they will fall back
in whatever we have for the most part
because they have to in a way but if we
can like you know be super specific
about the domain and leverage all of
that tacit knowledge about the domain
uh for this representation and
interaction that's where i think we can
do that very very very powerful things
great thank
you maybe i'll follow up with another
question here then um
um so you know another very powerful
representation is is language and text
and and so i'm curious how you think
uh language and and text in particular
[Music]
uh kind of fits into all of this
ah that's so that's an interesting
question so
texts really we cannot
do without
uh
and that's that's something that
actually the the the
the title of the paper you know that i
showed first like the the healthcare a
medical you know visual dashboard uh the
actual title of this paper is more text
please
because we've been like you know there's
been a lot of pushing for like you know
let's make everything visual let's
summarize everything let's have a look
of this nlp kind of you know things
doing out of the work and summarize
everything for us but that's true that
it doesn't work as well and there's a
strong demand for keeping all of the you
know raw data and text
you know
data because
not only because the the
the automated methods are not
uh super perfect but you know there are
plenty of subtleties in the text in the
way that person people captured you know
nuances in in the
in the patient record in our case that
that um it's very difficult to maintain
whenever we try to translate that in a
visualization
so instead yeah i think there's a lot of
and i see more and more work going in
that direction trying to really like you
know have them be combined so
visualization is useful to
make sense of like you know that
informational space that our textual you
know um
document uh or collection of documents
might be and it's used to summarize get
the big picture but also navigate and so
they need to work in par so yeah
absolutely text cannot be removed i
think
uh cannot always be like fully
summarized uh and and i think they have
that you know they need an equal place
and at least that's what we found you
know in this particular project more
texts please because
it's it's um it's too
optimistic to believe that the
visualization we will capture all of the
nuances in there does it does it answer
your question yeah it does i i i'll just
follow up briefly because i think
there's some other questions as well but
you know
the one thing i've been curious about is
in the work that you showed on analogies
for large numbers um
it seems like a lot of the work is being
done by the text and
and
you know how much do you need visuals in
that case at all
maybe that's an open question or maybe
you've done some experiments there i i
don't know
uh like you mean like for the concrete
scale yeah yeah the concrete scale is
stuff yeah oh no i showed first like you
know what yeah um no it doesn't that
doesn't have to be the text so if you
look at know the can of coke and you
look at the sugar cubes on the side
i agree yeah
it is true that if i didn't tell you the
story you might not directly make the
connection whether you know what does it
mean to have sugar cubes are there like
you know associated to that and that's
uh one of the arguments that actually uh
alberto cairo makes a lot about uh
visualization a picture is he's worth a
thousand words he combat that ideal by
saying no we need explanations but if
they interpret them so yes there's
there's still a need uh sometimes um
uh oftentimes to have like these little
you know explanations annotations and uh
to be able to decode correctly the
visualization but back to what i was
saying at the beginning you know you may
miss out on some of those
or you might be like you know biased
also by some of those yes i haven't
conducted experiments myself about the
texts these textbooks
uh doing some of this work actually as
of right now
uh investigating different ways of
framing you know the text and the
visualization which jessica harmon has
done also
uh but uh but yeah it showed that you
know text can have an influence
absolutely on the way you interpret the
visualization yeah
thank you um
questions from the audience
yes i see elizabeth
hello
um
i was wondering if you could touch you
actually talked a little bit about it by
the question that he just asked a touch
on how when you create a visualization
you aren't really just showing the data
but you're also suggesting an
interpretation of the data just by how
you arrange it through the visualization
um which you touched a little bit when
you showed like the different axes but
also in terms of like showing how they
increase
depending on how you choose to organize
it like you need to say there's an
increase you can see there's not an
increase and you can also say there's a
decrease depending on what data that you
have
and how do you
i guess ensure as a designer and making
these visualizations whether it be like
production or something
that you don't accidentally like put in
like a biases of like there's increased
decrease from that it's been showing
this data and ensure that it becomes
still like their interpretation of the
data rather than the person who creates
the visualization
so i if sorry the the sound was a little
bit uh noisy uh to reformulate the
question i think you refer to the to the
work where we do create like with a
checklist
and we show
oh yeah yeah well i refer to that but in
general more like for example yeah
but if i cut it correctly it's like you
know whenever we create that or we
identify that might be a problem and
that we create this visualization how do
we make sure that we do not bias in a
certain way is that is that correct of
the questions
okay yeah no you're absolutely right
those uh checklists are not completely
uh would it prove the rules actually
that are behind them they are based on
textbooks like you know uh rules but uh
god knows how many uh you know um
exceptions to the rules there are
because of the context because of you
know
something that is normal like maybe some
you know uh clinical in that particular
case uh clinical you know studies
hasn't evolved and still like you know
you have exceeding value along an axis
or so on but uh it's normal because it
takes time for the for the thing to
resolve so you don't want to label the
problem over and over again you know
that it is there to stay at least for a
few days or something or it can also
like mislabel something so that's where
actually the
having this visual dashboard first you
know we have the checklist on the side
and the visual dashboard which is
open-ended without the annotations is
important because it still leaves that
free form kind of you know first
impression if you want to begin before
you go and take those creative views
so we believe it's like it it can act as
a powerful kind of mitigation strategy
because
you still are free to look at whatever
hypothesis you have
because you don't show only the created
views but you show this general purpose
dashboard now we haven't explicitly
evaluated that
and
and quantified or characterized that
but that's that's a very good question
yeah there are there are limitations to
like having a list that might
feel like too prescriptive and and bias
you in certain ways that's for sure
thank you
um
one last question
oh okay
maybe it was asked already all right
so um
well uh we're we're at the end of the
hour so thank you fanny again for the
great presentation and um you know
hopefully we'll be able to see you here
in california sometime soon
my pleasure yeah i i can't wait for the
next opportunity to come down and yeah i
wish i was i was there in person to see
everybody but yeah so it is but it was
still very much of a pleasure thank you
very much again for for uh for the
invitation and and for for being here
thank you all right